in many videos we have talked about how
a bill can become a law it first gets
introduced into the legislative branch
which in the united states is the u.s
congress at the federal level and if it
passes both houses of congress then the
bill will go to the president
and if the president signs the bill or
if the president vetoes the bill but
then it gets overruled by the
legislative then let's just assume that
the president signs
signs the bill then that bill becomes a
law
it becomes a law
but the question is is how is this law
actually implemented
and you might guess that that is the
work of the bureaucracy
and we've already talked about the
bureaucracy in multiple videos already
the bureaucracy is part of the executive
branch it's actually the bulk of federal
employees and as we'll see as part of
this implementing process the
bureaucracy has
authority on rulemaking and it also has
discretionary authority let me write
that down so the bureaucracy
bureaucracy
is going to implement the law and they
have different types of authority to do
so they have rule-making authority where
for specific circumstances they might
say hey this is how it's going to work
that the law itself does not specify but
based on what that law is trying to do
they're going to set some rules and as
we'll see the people working inside the
bureaucracy many of whom are experts on
whatever policy they're trying to
implement have some discretion on how
they actually implement this law so the
authority sometimes you'll hear
rule-making authority and discretionary
authority
and as an example of that we can look at
what is often known as title ix so this
right over here is title nine of the
education amendments of 1972 it passed
through congress and then was signed
into law by president nixon and it says
no person in the united states shall on
the basis of sex be excluded from
participation in be denied the benefits
of or be subjected to discrimination
under any education program or activity
receiving federal financial assistance
so this gets through the legislature
president nixon signs it becomes a law
but then how does this thing actually
get implemented and so this as we've
already talked about is the job of the
bureaucracy and it's not just one
department
many departments of the federal
government are going to have to think
about how do they implement this statute
right over here
and as an example of how say the
department of education thought about it
i'll give you a little bit of an excerpt
from their rules and regulations
so this right over here is part of the
rules and regulations from the
department of education
in their attempt to implement title ix
and as i read think about the what part
of this really shows the bureaucracy's
rule-making authority and what part
shows its discretionary authority
every application for federal financial
assistance shall as condition of its
approval contain or be accompanied by an
assurance from the applicant or
recipient
satisfactory to the assistant secretary
that the education program or activity
operated by the applicant or recipient
and to which this part applies will be
operated in compliance with this part
so that is a mouthful i will help you
parse it a little bit so in this
document the term applicant and
recipient these are the institutions
that are either applying for federal
assistance or have already received
financial assistance and saying every
application for federal financial
assistance shall as condition for its
approval contain or be accompanied by an
assurance from the applicant or
recipient so the big picture this whole
thing
is a rule that is being set up by the
office of civil rights within the
department of education so it clearly
shows rule-making authority and this is
just one part of a much much much larger
document full of rules on how just the
department of education
is thinking about title ix and these
things have the rule of law even though
they every detail here has not been
passed through congress now of course
congress will have forms of oversight
over this and the supreme court can also
deem certain rules or regulations to be
unconstitutional if it thinks that they
are unconstitutional now another thing
in this clause right over here that i
just read you might have noticed
satisfactory to the assistant secretary
so it's the assistant secretary's
discretion as to whether an institution
has met the requirements so once again
this shows the discretionary authority
of the bureaucracy
so the big takeaway here is it is the
legislative branch that is responsible
for passing laws and then you have the
president that would sign something into
law but once it's a law there's a lot of
details to be worked out in terms of how
it's implemented and that is the job of
the bureaucracy in order to do that they
make rules and regulations and those
rules and regulations also have the
force of law
and on top of that there's going to be
opportunities for them to exercise their
discretion